Mysteries of Vernacular.
Odd: different from what is usual or expected.
Though the modern word "odd" has many meanings, mathematical and not,...
...they can all be traced back to the Indo-European root "uzdho," meaning "pointing upwards."
Inspired by the idea of a vertical pointed object,...
...speakers of Old Norse modified this root into a new word, "oddi,"...
...which was used to refer to a triangle, the simplest pointed object, geometrically speaking.
A triangle with a long point, like an arrowhead or a piece of land jutting out into the sea,...
...was recognized to have two paired angles and a third that stood alone.
And over time, "oddi" began to refer to something that wasn't matched or paired.
In Old Norse, "oddi" also came to mean any number indivisible by two.
And "odda mathr," the "odd man," was used to describe the unpaired man...
...whose vote could break a tie.
Though the English never called a triangle "odd,"...
...they did borrow the "odd" number and the "odd" man.
And finally, in the 16th century, the notion of the "odd man out"...
...gave rise to our modern meaning "peculiar."